yeah i think that i think that's
ridiculous people have such a short
memory of history first of all the
Kremlin even in Russia's reduced state
has the last time I checked thousands of
actual operational nuclear warheads so
when you have the power to push buttons
and destroy entire countries and
hundreds and millions of people that's
actually more power than even Sergey and
Larry have at Google I think by least
some measures secondly people forget
that there have been business tycoons I
mean you know the robber barons the
people that own the railroads the john d
rockefeller own most of the oil in the
country at one time that's pretty good
power so yeah bill gates's and steve
ballmer and the guys that run microsoft
are really powerful Steve Jobs is really
powerful the Google guys are really
powerful you know the flavor toujours
whoever is hot on the Internet is really
powerful the Internet itself is
obviously really powerful although it's
not controlled by anyone so you know
they're always been multiple centers of
power there's cultural power there's
military power there's economic power
there's business power we have all those
things today they're just different in
different names and I have thoroughly
enjoyed being able to cover in one part
of my career some of those Paris centers
and now and another part of my career
some others where there's a lot of
innovation I would say the Kremlin was
very innovative I wouldn't say the White
House was very innovative I think it's
great fun to talk to people who have
fascinating new ideas and the any
inclination and resources to try them
out but I don't think it's a new thing
that we have business figures who have a
lot
still have no idea just what the rise of
China and India means you know they have
enormous economic potential including by
the way a significant high-tech
potential and I'm not just talking about
call centers they have the potential to
invent and develop things that we have
become accustomed to seeing invented and
developed here and from the point of
view of the United States is a country
it will be very interesting to see what
happens in those countries because while
they do have these concentrations of
educated people and middle class and
people who are even wealthy and
entrepreneurial they also still are in
the majority full of extremely poor
uneducated people who have a right to a
future and how they distribute their
wealth and how they go about taking care
of their whole populations particularly
in case of China which is of course not
a free country is it's going to be a
fascinating situation